i'm going to show you what we have right
now which is a lot for this and they've
got some folks might be arrested that's
called being arrested party in hospice
in sanford so you committed a
billion-dollar institution home hey NFL
super bowl call it what you want so it's
a crime to be poor it's a poor dispo so
for folks who don't know the super bowl
is being hosted here in San Francisco
right now super bowl for you um what all
this protest want to do is bring alert
bring awareness to homelessness in the
city and what they say is me referees
efforts to eject the homelessness so the
folks 250 for the superbowl don't see
how he has reason to folks are holding
up
the police have said if the town on the
ground then once they hit the ground
will be in violation and i'm here
because i live in the greatest city on
the face of this planet and I love San
Francisco unfortunately my mayor doesn't
think that this is the city for everyone
is good a city of acceptance and
tolerance and kindness and compassion
and that is not what our mayor showing
us right now that is not what our police
chief is showing us right now these are
human beings the world is watching us
right now this country is watching us
how we treat the least among us will be
recorded and we cannot stand back all
bad things happen to human beings in our
city and I am ashamed but I live in a
city that allows this to happen merit
leave where are you we ask for your
leadership we ask for your guidance
six officers deep because they give us
and them so strange
guys I'm going to step away from this
real quick and see what this other
protest over here is about and indeed it
is just about another coalition of folks
in joining this protest um we have the
few people organizing this protest one
is a guy named broke-ass stuart another
is that I think it's for the coalition
against homelessness without money with
50 million dollars over to do we get
5,000 people off the streets of San
Francisco in the home that would almost
ameliorate homelessness all together in
this city but now we got a party over
there and said in they got chance on the
ground you notice that I know man but I
was real it's important that we're out
here doing this standing up for our
neighbors send up the people most
fragile our society that's all the ones
i want to say thank you for being here
thank you for having the guts to stick
up for your city for your neighbors hi
guys this is sarah again for aj+ were
broadcasting live from thank you I'm
broadcasting live i'm here with
broke-ass stuart okay um from the powder
how do we call this rally this tackle
homelessness tackle whole mrs. rally
here in San Francisco talking about
a lack of city at lack of accommodations
for homelessness and the criminalization
of homelessness here in San Francisco in
the lead-up to the Super Bowl an MA in
far beyond ok so I'm here with the guy
named broke-ass stuart he ran for mayor
if you're in san francisco i'm sure you
already know he's going to talk to us a
little about what's going on so high hey
Stu doing tell me about why you're here
today I'm here because a few months back
when the mayor said the homeless had to
leave for the superbowl thought it was
bullshit so I reached out to the coast
and homelessness I said hey y'all we
should we should make a we should make
an action and we should all you know we
got to stick up for the people who can't
always necessarily stick up for
themselves and that's what we did we
have thousands of people out here ya go
out here you know taking up with their
fellow San Franciscans sorry amazing
yeah ok um
we've got a lot of folks who are at
least guys who are speaking their
solidarity this yeah so tell me about
what your role was in the organization
acres well I said I was out to the
coalition watch your step when I recited
the coalition I said hey if y'all handle
the actual like hardtack of it I'll get
people to show up yeah we did yeah look
at this it's crazy yeah and tell me
about the police presence here what do
you really like it yeah man I spent
would be a lot of police yeah you know
but you know we've heard the great thing
about this country is that we can
legally do this okay you can talk shit
about them in front of them and then I'm
gonna shoot us most of time so great
although I was surprised to hear that
the perhaps or I don't know if this is
true but there were snipers on us okay I
saw some diapers are there well you know
it's a super bowling I think I
everything after uh something after the
Boston Marathon things a little crazy
yeah fair enough they're so you know
fucking police stayed here right now
it's crazy right so tell me what are you
guys asking for exactly today a number
of thing you really want the city hall
to actually develop the political will
to to tackle homelessness real it's
doable it's actually cheaper to put
people in homes and have them on the
streets right and we want the city's new
group trying to negotiate the five
million dollars it paid to the nfo to
get that back if we want to see that
five million dollars go straight into
put getting 500 off the streets right
shall we I mean I've made all your
people off the streets right now right
now he's totally I tell me about like
how the
Super Bowl specifically affects hook
homeless folks right now well what
happened was that the mayor said y'all
gonna go and they push the crystal homes
you roll out of downtown all over the
city he's placing them and give a huge
homeless encampment under the freeway in
Division right oh that's where are we
going right now oh I don't know okay
cool and warm where were the homeless
people this place to uh they were just
placed a division street for a while and
then once I got out to media they home
is the dog BBW the cops came up and
swept that moshe taking they're taking
their only because possessions are these
people who have nothing and throwing
them in a truck and driving off right is
the middle of El Nino undertaking
people's fucking intense away from them
and what are we going to do tell us tell
us what we're going to do right now even
if we don't know exactly where we're
going I think we're just out of
demonstrating we're bringing the word to
the people and maybe he's an episode
maybe saying that's little camp okay
cool was awesome talking to you thanks
so much we had a lot of folks saying
what up so your big stores great